hey guys it's me jasmine and today we're
making a surprise recipe for my friends
katie and kelly wait i thought what i
thought we were making like a breakfast
you guys know how i'm always talking
about boba yeah and remember i showed
you guys those boba pancakes i had in
taiwan yes no and we're gonna make those
today a couple years ago i went to
taiwan i tried these super
delicious boba milk tea pancakes the
pancakes are black tea infused it's got
this amazingly light whipped cream on
top that's infused with milk and tea
literally tastes like a milk tea and
then we're going to top it with these
luscious boba pearls we can't go to
taiwan right now so i figured why not
bring taiwan to tasty we're not making
like a breakfast three ways no
surprise yes
what's with your shirt this is us it's
me katie and kelly are you the one
that's quacking yeah i talk loud and a
lot
let's cook so we're going to start by
infusing the heavy cream so i have a
small saucepan here just going to add
some heavy cream and then one black tea
bag i loved he infused anything so good
we're just gonna keep that on low for
about five minutes and then let it cool
we're making this early this is gonna be
used for the cream that goes on top of
the pancake but we need to let it chill
after so we can whip it so we're gonna
make this one first but we're not gonna
let this boil for too long because if it
gets too dark we're not gonna get that
beautiful white in the cream i'm using
black tea so it tastes like a milk tea
if you like other teas like green tea or
oolong i haven't tried it with them but
i feel like that could be something very
fun to experiment with in my opinion
this is the most important part of the
dish i feel like most of the boba flavor
comes from the cream this looks about
done i am going to transfer this into
the bowl here and cover it and let it
chill for about four hours y'all aren't
ready i'm excited i'm sad that we have
to wait four hours
you know what with patience
comes
great things isn't there a phrase with
greatness comes great responsibility
there's a patience one right with p with
p page
all good things come from those who wait
great things patience is what gives it
to you i'm the one god i got left behind
oh this is cooling we're going to make
boba that's maybe the best part i don't
know man everything's so good about this
dish let's make the boba first i have my
boba here i made this from scratch
earlier if you want to make boba from
scratch you should check out my video of
how to make bubble tea we'll add the
boba into the pot i'm just stirring this
so it doesn't stick to the bottom of the
pan and now i will let that boil for
about 20-25 minutes until they're done
the boba looks done let's take it out
look how cute they are sometimes when
you make it from scratch they can turn
out a little bit lighter just depending
on what sugar you use and you can also
flavor them if you want to have flavored
boba what's your favorite type of
flavored boba original if i ever go to a
new boba spot i'm always getting a
classic like signature milk tea with
boba no alterations to ice level or
sugar level because i want to know what
their standard is you got to have a good
base you know someone once called me a
boba elitist i was offended at first but
it's not my fault i have good taste in
boba so i'm just a boba connoisseur to
be less pretentious i'm gonna go rinse
these under cold water to keep them from
continuing cooking and then we are going
to make our brown sugar bath when you
make boba there is some sugar used to
make it but not a whole lot so the
flavor's not incredibly strong we're
actually using muscovado sugar but if
you only have brown sugar that works
totally fine water we're gonna cook this
down until it becomes a little thicker
what's the difference between muscovado
and brown sugar so muscovado sugar has a
higher molasses content i use muscovado
sugar more for a look thing to get it
nice and dark like the boba you're used
to seeing at boba shops but you can use
brown sugar also the higher content of
molasses in the muscle bottle sugar just
gives it a richer flavor it's leaving a
streak as i pull alongside the bottom of
the pan it's nice and thick and i'm just
going to pour this over my boba ooh baby
look at how dark that is dark and rich
i'm giving this a good stir so it's all
evenly coated i'm going to let the boba
soak for about an hour and in the
meantime let's get started making the
pancakes why are you so excited why
aren't you excited i am excited
i will be one lone duck on this shirt
okay okay the pancakes taste so good
they are tea infused and you can
definitely taste the flavor of the tea
in the pancakes i'm gonna take some milk
and then add some butter and a couple
bags of black tea i actually my mom is
friends with a tea master a taiwanese
tea master and we get all our tea from
his tea farm so i'm melting the butter
down and i'm infusing the tea
into the milk everything just needs to
fuse together like a happy marriage are
you nervous a little bit you know like
when you try so hard to give someone
something that you think they'll like
and they're like oh it's like getting
someone a gift it's one of those i'm a
little nervous so we're gonna let this
cook for about 10 minutes making sure to
really get that tea flavor out of the
tea bags but i'm not going to let it
come to a boil once your liquids are
boiling and you have your tea in there
you have a high chance of burning your
tea leaves which will just give it a
super bitter finish and we don't want
that especially not when i'm trying to
impress my friends
i actually throw boba parties so i'll
have people come over we'll make the
dough from scratch
everyone can roll it all up obviously i
haven't had one since the pandemic
started so once it's lifted bubble party
at my place the butter is melted and
it's been simmering for about 10 minutes
you can really see the deep rich color
of the tea that has come out now we are
just going to squeeze out the excess
liquid from the tea bag be careful
because uh if you puncture it all gonna
fall out now we're gonna just transfer
this we're gonna let this cool and then
come back and make the batter all right
it's time to make the pancake batter
this is actually the same pancake batter
from tasty 101 how to make the fluffiest
pancakes if you want to make those go
check it out this one is just tea
infused that's really the only
difference in this bowl here i'm going
to add some flour sugar salt baking
powder and baking soda i'm going to
whisk that in this bowl i have the tea
milk butter mixture it's cooled we're
going to add a teaspoon of vanilla and
then an egg yolk i'm just going to mix
this together this pancake was on the
list for what to do when i got to taiwan
and actually it was a really hard
journey finding it we couldn't find the
place that i was like tucked between
this famous mall but we just couldn't
find it i'm happy we went because they
don't serve these pancakes anymore they
change their recipe let's pour in this
mixture and we're just gonna fold it in
i'm gonna fold this so it doesn't get
over mixed some lumps are okay but not
too many i travel to eat i let my taste
buds guide me i feel like food is the
window to culture i love this one
specifically too because it's like a mix
american and taiwanese flavors pancake
boba
all right this looks good adding in the
egg white so i added in the egg white
after and it helps it rise a little
better making it more fluffy the batter
looks about done we're just gonna let
this rest for 15 to 30 minutes let the
gluten relax and that'll help make it
light and fluffy when we cook them it's
time to make the pancakes i'm gonna add
some butter we're just gonna let that
melt we're going to add some batter i'm
doing a third cup but these are going to
be large large pancakes in the cafe it's
nice and large very generous they know
that you would want more than a regular
sized pancake so you're going to deliver
oh hell yeah especially if it's for my
friends we're cooking it on medium low
heat there's some extra sugar in the
spatter to make that milk tea flavor
really come to life and we're just going
to cook it for about four minutes and
until we see these bubbles rise and then
they're ready to flip wow she's gorgeous
yes the color's beautiful like a royal
milk tea
okay this looks good i'm gonna plate
this i'm just gonna keep doing this
until we're out of batter
all right now we're gonna make the cream
again this is the best part so we're
gonna start with that infused cream that
we made at the very beginning
mascarpone and powdered sugar it was so
hard to find the mascarpone i was
standing in the cheese section for so
long and i couldn't find it and then i
finally found it in the charcuterie
section so tip go to the charcuterie
section if you are trying to make these
pancakes so we're going to mix it and
start it on low and slowly build up to
medium speed we want it to be thicker
but still slightly runny because that
cream has that very nice glossy finish
on it but still runs down the pancakes
and drapes over it like beautiful
curtains the colors definitely looking
exactly like it did in taiwan it's got a
good texture that will lock onto the
pancakes and mesh well with the boba all
right this is beautiful
not too thick not too runny let's get to
assembling
moment of truth it's time for assembly
we have our pancakes our boba that has
been sitting in the brown sugar bath for
an hour in our cream that was just
freshly made so we're going to start
with taking one pancake and placing some
boba on top now we're going to top it
with our second pancake add more boba
we're going to keep doing this until we
have four pancakes stacked now we can
top it with our milk tea cream that is
beautiful so fluffy look at the way it's
just falling down the sides it's like a
beautiful waterfall finally we're gonna
top it with a scoop of boba oh my god
okay it's done all the hard work and
waiting oh i'm so excited it feels like
we're really just right back in taiwan
at bellapak cafe i'm really excited to
share this with katie and kelly i can't
wait for them to try it this looks
incredible the cream looks like actual
clouds
okay eat it
if i could curse i would this is so
good i cannot believe it the pancakes
are fluffy just like she said the boba
is chewy and tender you can tell that
they're homemade it literally tastes
like i'm drinking a boba tea i'm gonna
take this and maybe this one for later
this is so good jasmine yeah this looks
look at all those layers of boba and
pancake i'm very excited shall i you
shall
the texture is really crazy with the
boba and the pancake the muscovado sugar
reminds me of like sticky toffee pudding
it's just got these nice mapley notes
almost in there i really think that the
milk cream tea part that is what sells
it with the bob on top those two things
together that's a dine in my pairing and
it really does taste like boba tea if
you haven't had bobo so you've had fresh
boba baby
yeah
that's the ending that's the ending oh
yes
tasty remix
[Music]
you